. Joe Biden believes that Donald Trump should
not continue receiving intelligence briefings
and is going to stop them.
Joe Biden was interviewed on CBS Evening News
on Friday.
Norah O'Donnell asked him about this and Joe
Biden said he should stop getting the intelligence
briefings.
You may know, you may not you may know that
former presidents receive intelligence briefings
even thereafter, even after they're out of
office.
And it includes classified information.
But we have a very I don't want to say very
unique.
It's just unique.
It's a unique situation in which Donald Trump
continuing to receive these briefings may
actually pose a national security risk.
And Trump Trump couldn't even be trusted with
classified information as president.
Of course, he can't be trusted with classified
information back as a private citizen.
And this is the first time that a former president
is being cut out of briefings.
And here is Joe Biden explaining why should
former President Trump still receive intelligence
briefings?
I think not.
Why not?
Because of his erratic behavior unrelated
to the insurrection.
I mean, you've called him an existential threat.
You've called him dangerous.
You've called him reckless.
You have I believe it.
What's your worst fear if he continues to
get these intelligence briefings?
I'd rather not speculate out loud, I just
think that there is no need for him to have
that intelligence briefing.
What value is giving him an intelligence briefing?
What impact does he have at all other than
the fact he might slip and say something?
Joe Biden is absolutely correct.
Donald Trump's intelligence briefings should
have been cut off on the first day that he
was out of office.
Something nobody is saying but is relevant
is the question of is Trump even getting them?
If he is, is he listening?
If he's listening?
Does he remember or understand the content
of them?
And then what is he doing with that information
morally?
Donald Trump is exactly the type of person
who would figure out how to monetize or trade
access to that information if he came up with
a way to do it.
I don't know that he's actually clever enough
to figure out a way to do it.
But Trump is a sort of like who's the highest
bidder for what I know type of guy.
Why even take a chance?
Democratic Congressman Adam Schiff has been
talking about this for a while.
He said a couple of weeks ago, days before
Trump left office, a Trump shouldn't get these
briefings.
And he makes another great point as to why
he leaves office.
He should be denied access to intelligence
briefings.
Would you urge the Biden administration to
do that?
Absolutely, there's no circumstance in which
this president should get another intelligence
briefing, not now, not in the future.
I don't think he can be trusted with it now
and in the future.
He certainly can't be trusted.
Indeed, there were, I think, any number of
intelligence partners of ours around the world
who probably started withholding information
from us because they didn't trust the president
would safeguard that information to protect
the sources and methods.
This is a really good point.
Aside from what Trump will do with the information,
we know that during Trump's presidency, many
of our allies were being more careful about
what they told the United States for fear
it would get to Trump and Trump would spill
the beans.
If they know Trump still gets intelligence
briefings that might continue cutting Trump
off from the intelligence briefings.
Not only is the right decision from a national
security standpoint, it probably helps revive
some of our relationships, including as far
as intelligence sharing is concerned with
other countries.
That's something that is a big task for Joe
Biden, reestablishing some of those damaged
relationships.
Joe Biden is right to do this.
And the official announcement about it happening
should be coming any moment now.